You
I'm talking now my voice is too low. If I could really close, yes.
I've worked on this for several hours and if it's still not working, then I'm gonna cry.
It's not working. I'm using you.
I'm really gonna cry.
It's still too quiet.
I don't know.
Does that work?
Hello?
Oh, my cheek is still white.
Can you hear me?
Okay, I'm really sad.
Nothing's working today and I'm kind of upset.
The one thing that was bothering me is that I couldn't change one of my eyelashes to the right color because the mesh is just not working.
I apologize if you can hear my AC.
I'll put on some rain.
I hope the rain helps.
I didn't want to cancel though because I wanted to spend time with you today.
I have allergies. That's why I'm sniffling by the way.
My head would stay connected to my body.
Do you think I look cute?
Do I look nice?
I also think there's a delay.
Again, I don't know why.
She needs reassurance. She's been stressed out today.
I'm working with stuff and I'm tired of technology.
I'm moving the model with my mouth so I'm not all the way over here.
Hi, my name is Sheeby Cottonbomb and today we're going to be doing an ASMR.
It's going to be Improv ASMR.
I'm kind of mad that my stream is not doing the right latency because Improv is needed and chat interaction is needed.
Sorry if I sniffle in your ear.
I should change the title to You Give Yaro Sheeby Therapy because she's stressed out.
What do you mean I'm just ahead?
I don't know what you're talking about.
My allergies are kidding me this morning.
I don't feel good.
I'm having a pain flare up so I don't really feel good right now either.
I won't get my white cheek.
Let me fix that.
This might be very scuffed ASMR. I apologize.
I'm still pissed. I can't color my one eyelash.
Did I?
I should have posted on the wrong account.
Oh my god, I'm going to lose a guy this way.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, it's one of those things.
I'll probably just cut all of this out of the vod.
What was I going to do? I was going to color my cheek.
I can't do that right now. It doesn't matter.
No, it doesn't matter to me.
I'm very...
Don't worry about how my head is disconnected.
I don't really know how to explain that I'm not myself today.
But I'm not myself today, as you can see.
I'm almost wishing I could be babyed right now.
Hold on.
Now you throw my head in the trash.
Anyways, how's it going?
One moment.
I will remind you that my Bunspeak accent comes out when I'm...
feeling some types of way.
But don't worry.
It'll change.
Is there a voice in the background?
It's my desktop audio.
Do you like my bedroom? I took it from Canvo.
No.
Nobody can see that, right?
Maybe I should not do this on stream.
Don't look.
Don't worry about it.
That's close enough.
Ahem.
I love that.
I look very cute. I can't wait to get hands.
I'm stressing.
Okay, yeah.
Yaru Dolhan gets babyed by chat, maybe.
Okay, um, how long?
Okay, I've been streaming for 16 minutes.
I won't cut 16 minutes.
So the roleplay today is going to be improved.
It's going to be more scuffed than you think it is, because I'm kind of doing stuff off the rip.
I'm going to do all the doughnose and stuff at the end and all that.
Yeah.
What if I told you, like, you want this color?
Not good, because I'm going to be this color eventually.
Um, so this is going to require some chat interaction.
Are you ready to rumble?
I have some stuff.
I'm used to this scuff, madam. It's fine.
Why am I holding your hair?
Hmm.
What was that about?
You're sleepy already?
The scene is, you're my classmate.
Why did you over my house?
Because we can work on a project together.
My body's going to be jumping back and forth.
It's a rainy day.
And you don't have any power at your house.
So we're doing that at mine. I hope you don't mind.
Is that okay with you?
It better be okay with you. You don't really have a choice in this.
This is my bedroom.
I'm going to...
I'm going to put my body on the bed and you can stare at her from over there.
This is mine.
Pink is my favorite color.
I'm going to start now.
Hey, yeah. You can put yourself anywhere. Make yourself at home.
I guess we better get ready and get started on that project.
Did you remember to bring the assignment?
No.
Do you even remember what the assignment is?
You don't?
I knew I shouldn't have partnered with you.
I was hoping that you'd do all the work because I thought you were one of the smarter kids.
I guess I was wrong. I guess you're just still dumb.
What's that on my bed?
Oh, it's just my body.
Don't worry about that.
Sorry if my AC's loud. It has been a pretty hot one out there.
Please don't stare at her though. That's kind of rude. Please don't stare at my body.
She's, you know, just trying to hang out.
You fell asleep in class when the teacher was telling us?
I would never have ever thought that from you. Have you been getting sleep?
Alright. Maybe you should work on getting better sleep.
Well, so, we have a history project.
It has to do with 18th century literature and its impact on history.
I think. Hold on. Let me go on my phone real quick. I'll tell you what the teacher emailed me.
Hold on.
No.
Oh my god, where's this freaking email?
My phone turned into a book.
Oh, it's the history of magic. That's what it is. That's why I managed to turn my phone into a book.
My body's holding the phone. I have two phones.
You only know about 17th century literature? You're going to be absolutely useless.
Can we look at the history of anthropomorphic girls? I think that's a little bit off topic.
Anyways, you can come and sit with me on the bed and we can start.
Did you bring your notebook with you for class?
You did? Okay. Cool.
Hold on. Let me just tuck my head on my body.
Give me a moment.
Hold on. My head's still a little bit too big.
Him.
Why don't you come sit?
Just make yourself comfortable. Just come sit down.
Is there a problem?
Yeah, you can sit on my butt. Where else are you going to sit? That chair?
I guess you could sit there too if you wanted to, but it will be easier if you sit nice and close to me.
Let me grab my notebook.
Okay, I got it.
Alright, so do you mind if I copy some of your notes?
Can you lay on my lap? Well, that's a little bit too close for comfort.
Yeah, and you're either close to me so I can read your notes and copy some of them.
Okay? Thank you.
Alright, so you said that you would do this.
You would do that.
What does that say? What does that say? I can't really read your writing.
What is it? I'll come back to that later, I guess.
Okay.
And then you're right there.
Okay, what if I...
I'm not coincidentally wrong.
You put...
You regard an eye.
That's alright. My handwriting is best you do.
I'm getting bored reading all your stupid words anyways.
I thought you were supposed to be the smart one. I think my notes are better than yours.
I don't know if I should even bother copying these.
Yeah, you still spoke coincidentally incorrect.
Can you spell supercalifragilisticexpialidocious?
Thank you.
X-P-M-Dosh.
S-U-P-E-R-C-A-L-I-F-R-A-G.
I-L-I-S-T-I-C-E-X-P-I-A-L-A-D-O-C-I-O-U-S.
Supercalifragilisticexpialidocious.
I'm sorry. That was correct.
Oh, you can spell it, right? You still hope.
Unless you're just typing what I just told you.
Even the sound of it is something quite atrocious.
Did you ever watch Mary Poppins?
I don't know.
Yeah, it's a real word.
Look it up. Wake up supercalifragilisticexpialidocious.
And then your mouth.
I'm going to pop my head on then.
I'm sorry.
I'm married Poppins, you know.
I think that we're even getting a little louder.
I hope you don't mind. You can still hear me, right?
Do you have another page I can copy?
Cool.
It's pretty humid outside.
I think I need a sharpener in my pencil, but I don't have a pencil sharpener.
Do you have a pencil I can borrow?
Did I hear about the drama between Stacy and her mom?
I heard that Stacy's mom has got it going on.
That's all I've heard though.
I don't know what you've heard.
Can we chew on your pencils?
I love chewing on pencils.
Pencil chewing.
It's quite tasty to be honest.
I don't like chewing on an eraser.
Thank you for letting me borrow your pencil that you want.
Have you ever seen Stacy's mom?
I haven't seen her.
Is she hot?
What does that word say?
I said what does that word say?
That one right there.
Can you tell me what that word says?
It says what?
You can't write that.
Why would you write that?
That wasn't part of the lesson.
I gotta sneeze.
Okay.
I don't think you're listening to me.
What does that say?
You don't know what it says?
Are you blind?
I think you're blind.
What's up with that?
I don't know.
It says something in the...
You're writing inappropriate things.
Is this not...
Are you writing inappropriate things?
I don't...
I'm just gonna skip that section
because I don't know what you were writing.
You're really weird.
You're like really really weird.
I wish we weren't lab partners.
It says street class but we're lab partners.
Don't question it.
We're partners in a lot of things.
What's up with that?
Why are you so...
You do need your glasses?
Then grab your glasses.
That says bloodonkers.
Why would you write bloodonkers?
Why are you so naughty?
That's really inappropriate.
What does that say?
Can you repeat...
Can you say this what you wrote out loud?
Because I need to hear you say it.
It's a history line, exactly.
We're always partners.
We're partners in biology.
We're partners in anatomy.
We're partners together in history class.
I'm kind of sick of seeing you in my face.
I didn't even want to light you over my house.
My mom said I had to light you over my house.
Because you're one of the kids and you're small weird.
You're one of the weird kids that sits alone.
And don't you like a minet or something?
What is it called?
Like cartoons?
Are you like a little too old for cartoons?
Peanuts?
What is peanuts?
I don't know what that means.
I don't...
What's going on here?
What's up with that?
Anime?
Whatever the fuck that is, I don't really care about it.
Why do you like anime?
Anime is weird.
Anime is for weirdos.
Your mom likes me though?
No, she doesn't.
Wait, now I have to ask her.
I'm weird sometimes.
What's this anime called?
You have a manga?
A manga?
What is...
You have a comic book in your backpack?
What does it say?
Is it in Japanese?
I can't read Japanese.
It's not in Japanese?
Oh, the cover is in Japanese.
Oh, I got those nipples.
Why do you have to read this from right to left?
That's really confusing.
A mango?
I wish I had a mango.
Your mom likes me, and if you keep being unpolite, I'm going to hit her.
Don't hit on my mom.
That's weird.
You're weirdo.
You like anime and you want to hit on people's moms?
What's...
It's called a dojinshi?
What is that?
Can I see it?
Give it to me.
Over.
Just let me see it.
Why are you fighting me?
Why would you bring it out of your backpack if you weren't going to show it to me?
Don't run away from me.
Hand it over.
Thank you very much.
Let me look through it.
I can't even see what this is saying.
Oh, mom.
Okay.
What the heck is this?
What are you reading?
What?
Did you just call me a baka?
What the heck is a baka?
Why are you looking at this stuff at school?
Wait, where did you get it?
How did you get this?
Did they help us in the school library?
Do you have more of this?
Is this kind of hot?
Is this kind of cool?
I can't tell what's going on.
Why can't I see through her?
That's a lot of liquid.
What is that?
Is that supposed to be what I think it's supposed to be?
It's a gyaru dosi?
What's a gyaru?
Gyaru?
I don't know what that is.
My name is Shibi, right?
Yeah?
That's what my mom named me.
After the Queen of Shiba, African Princess.
I guess this is kind of cool.
It's kind of weird that you read this at school, though.
Do you, like, do anything about it?
I'm not so sure about this.
This is some graphic stuff.
Is it Japanese fashion trend?
Can you show me a picture on your phone?
I can't really tell what's going on in this picture.
It's like she's up high.
Her legs are kind of all over the place.
When you're bored at school, what do you do?
I don't think you do this.
I don't think you do that.
I don't think anybody does that.
Why would you do that?
You'd rather not say?
Why are you being shy with me?
Why did you take this out of your backpack then?
Huh? Tell me.
Why do you have this?
Where did you get this?
It's kind of weird that you have this.
The art's nice or whatever.
But, like, I don't...
I'm not sure about this one.
This is kind of weird.
You don't read it at school.
You're holding it for a friend.
You know, you do hang out with weird people.
And you do kind of smell bad.
Like...
Why do you smell so bad?
Yeah, my nose is stuffy, but I can still tell
that you smell so bad.
My God.
Do you, like, ever shower?
Like, didn't we have, like, gym class today?
When was the last time you showered?
I need to blow my nose.
Because I need to blow off this stinky...
Your shower is broken.
I guess you can, you know...
You can shower in my house if you want.
I'm sure my...
I have...
My older brother came, like...
Like, he borrowed someone's clothes.
I don't know if they'll fit you, though.
Maybe you can fit into my sister's clothes.
So if you decide to take a shower,
you can dress up in my sister's clothes.
Or, you know, you're kind of small.
Maybe you can fit my clothes.
I better have a t-shirt for you.
Yeah, I...
You're gonna...
You're gonna need that shower, I think.
Because, like...
Yeah, my sister.
Oh, my brother.
My sister, if it were that...
She doesn't have to know.
We have to tell her.
I read her panties all the time.
Don't tell her I said that.
Hmm...
Is my sister single?
Well, she's 14, so you tell me.
I just think we'd fit her clothes,
because you guys are, like, the same size.
I think I gotta sneeze again.
Ah!
She has cute clothes, and I like to take them.
I'm kidding.
She's my age.
And we're both in school.
We're literally in the same grade.
She's my twin sister.
You've seen her before.
Shibani?
You've seen Shibani?
That's my sister.
I'm Shibani.
And my sister is Shibani.
We have very different tastes.
My brother right now thinks he's, like, a London drill rapper.
He might be able to hear him in the next room.
Yeah, he's kind of weird.
Yeah, Shibani is darkness.
She calls herself that.
Her real name is really just, um...
Shibritney, but if she don't tell her, I told you that.
She hates her name.
I'm Shibethani.
She's technically Shibritney,
but she likes to be called Shibani.
Shibani.
I'm a really big family.
I need a sneeze.
That?
Phew!
I don't know my panic.
I'm not a strong sneeze.
I mean, don't worry about it.
Um, does she call me a prep?
Yeah, she does.
I don't know why she does that.
I don't know.
Does your brother have a sister complex?
I don't know what that means.
Does he have a stroke?
Should we call an ambulance?
Yeah, you know, we did that before,
but he just got mad at us.
So, it is what it is.
Thank you.
Um, I guess since I'm done copying your notes and stuff
and you showed me that weird book,
I'm just going to hop on the computer
and I'm going to, you know,
I'm just going to do some re...
I left my body behind.
Um, I'm just going to do some research.
Let me sit better in this chair.
My body is stuck.
There we go.
I was kind of, like, up in the air.
Okay, um, I'm not doing research on a weird thing.
On a weird book.
I'm just going to do some typing.
I need to set my keyboard up.
Don't worry when I'm looking up,
it's none of your business, okay?
You just say you think I look cute?
That's kind of weird for you to say.
We're just, we're just studying together.
Thanks, I guess.
You weirdo.
Whatever.
Anyways, I'm going to keep looking up the research.
Oh, there's a lot of these.
This doesn't really have to do with our project,
but it's very interesting.
How did you get into this dojinsha?
Anything about that?
Hey, my head's kind of staying on.
Nope, I'm slowly drifting away.
I don't know how that works.
Hmm.
Interesting.
I can drink a water.
Yeah, I drink cloud, whatever.
Do you have a problem?
Why did you send me a number?
You want me to look up a number?
Okay, what is it?
Okay, okay.
What is this?
A friend said the art reminded him of someone in our class.
Who did that?
Who did it look like in our class?
Who in our class looks like that?
Oh, my God.
This is what you like to look at?
I think I should just go back to the project,
because I don't even know if we should be in the same room together anymore.
It's kind of weird to me now.
It's kind of weird to me now, girl.
Anyways, I will continue to type up the paper.
Is that okay with you if I type up the paper?
Or do you want to type up the paper?
I don't want to look at the art you like anymore.
I don't really think this is art.
This is just weird.
Why are you so mean?
Come on, why?
Don't understand.
You want to type it?
You want me to type it?
I can type it.
You already wrote some strong bits.
Okay, fine.
Fine, fine, fine.
You can just lay on the bed.
Shoot me some ideas to write about for our literature,
history literature paper.
About 18th century literature, yeah.
What?
Okay, I can add that.
I don't like that word.
What's another word for big?
Yeah, I know, I could look it up in this episode.
I don't want.
What's another word for cylinder?
Big cylinder?
Humongous?
Okay, humongous cylinder, but from your own cylinder or something?
That cylinder is so basic.
Massive.
I like massive.
Massive cylinders are good.
Rod?
I get it.
Rod is a cylinder.
Shaft?
Hmm, let me see how it works.
In this essay, me and anonymous, I can call you that, right?
Yeah?
Okay.
Will be analyzing the historical importance of humongous rods in 18th century literature.
Yes, I think that's good.
Do you think that does that sound okay to you?
No credit?
What do you mean no credit?
That's your name.
You write that every time I look at your paper.
I'm not cheating on you or anything.
I'm not cheating off of you.
I mean, it's not like we were together in the first place.
It's not like I could cheat on you anyway.
It's not like I ignored it suddenly.
I mean, cheat off your papers.
I mean, no, I don't.
No, I don't.
How can you cheat off your papers?
You write your name as anonymous, so I thought that was your name.
Let me, I'm just going to Google some photos for the insert into the paper of humongous
rods in 18th century.
Okay.
Humongous rods in 18th century literature.
Excuse me.
Oh, I didn't know they had this sort of stuff back then, but this is not what I meant.
I don't, what is going on in this photo?
Can you come here?
Come here.
Get off the bed.
Can you tell me what's on it?
It's a what.
Or don't, what?
No way.
You're joking.
Humongous rods.
That's something like a humongous rod I was looking for.
That's so weird.
I was like, I'm sorry.
Ok get away from me Particularly
It's amazing press I don't...
Of All this just like what animals do I can't put that in
Yea Yea Yea lets add that
And during research
What's the author's name? What was the author's name of that article? Do you remember the teacher told us in class?
Does anybody know? Because I don't know. Do you know what the author's name was? I can't really remember. I have a really bad memory.
Why do I think the teacher is quite the killer? So if we write this stuff, I don't know if we're not in the mood. It's fine. It's fine.
Oh yeah, Hugh Janus. Yeah, okay. Yeah, but the author's Hugh and Janus. Well, the Janus or Janus? Janus? Okay.
Oh yeah, I forgot about the author, Mike Coney. Mike Coney was very prevalent. Very important in this day and age. Let me look up Mike Coney.
I don't know what these tacos are doing on this, but that's fun. Some of these girls look like me. What's up with that?
I'll add that in. Oh, the teacher mentioned something about a very important event over. Oh my gosh, you're right. I see. I'm kind of, you know what?
I apologize for picking on you earlier. You see, I know that you're really smart and I'm sorry that sometimes I take you for granted and I'm really sorry about that.
I'm sorry for all the names I called you behind your back. Like, I called you stinky and I thought you were weird and I said you were dumb and I said you have no friends and no one will love you and that you're a piece of trash, but I didn't mean it. I didn't mean it, okay?
Um, but let me add that stuff. The reconnaissance or the renaissance?
Okay. There's a lot of good names. Thank you. Keep them coming. Keep them coming. Keep them coming.
Hmm. There's a lot of good information. Especially after the earthquake in Italy during a holy day. Okay. Do you kind of like when I insult you?
Do you like when I insult you? That's weird.
It was the start of the enlightenment. Yes, but that was 16th century. It was not 18th century. Thank you, other classmate, that's happened to poke her head into the room.
Okay. I messed up. I need to raise this tie by a graph. Oh, I can hold down the button. Oh. Anyway. You have self-esteem problems? Why do you have self-esteem problems? You don't need self-esteem problems.
I know you smell bad, but I guess you're a little cute. Only a little. Forget I said it. You're still weird. I'm not talking through after this project.
That's a lot of typing.
There's an illustrative work on the treatment of 18th century prisons reenact the present day. Okay. I'll type that in.
What did you say? You want me to go out with you? I can't do that. My mom says I'm not allowed to date. I'll think about it.
Oh. Those are images. I don't think we can include this in our project. I need a tissue.
Can you pass me the tissue? This is my normal thing now. You're rubbing a tissue over your face before you get it.
I think I hear my mom coming. She's probably going to ask us if we want any food, so you can tell her what you want.
Honey, did you and your friend want to snack? Oh, you'll tell me later. All right. Keep me in the nose, sweetheart.
You've got to tell me what you want, and then I'll tell my mom. Oh, hi. I think we have more classmates joining us for our project.
We are writing about 18th century literature and its impact on history.
My name is Shababani.
Stop saying my mom is hot. She's nice, but she's not hot. My aunt taught her. My aunt, she'd be really hot. She runs a hotel. It's really cool. I'm not there sometimes. She lets me swim in the pool. You like pool?
Yeah? Oh, maybe I'll make you some time.
Have you heard of it? It's called Wonderland Hotel. How's it go? Like an Alice Wonderland thing? It's pretty cool.
My mom? I don't know what the other one is.
I haven't seen her talk to anybody. She never brings people around. And if they do, they're usually wearing a mask, and usually it's a weird scary mask, and mom doesn't like it when she brings them around.
They're also on leashes. I don't know why. But I like the style, though. That's why I wear this collar. I think it's cute.
My older brother says it makes me look subby. I don't know what subby means. I like sub. Yeah, I'll take you some time. I guess. She's not a date or anything. It's not a date.
Um, anyways, I think I'm done with typing. Can you, like, proofread this for me?
Come on. Sorry. My family is little hands. I don't know if you know this.
Subby is playing for Subaru with cars. Oh, I like cars. Cars are cool. They go vroom. Vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom.
Yeah, we're bullhound rabbits.
Vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom. Do you like cars? I like cars.
I um, I can lightning McQueen. Yeah
You like lightning McQueen? I love cars
Um, so what do you think of the paper?
Okay
I guess I can rewrite this paragraph or maybe I should just make you do it
Since you want to be so bossy and just lay on my back
You know what I should do
I want you to stand up
Stand up
Thank you
Sit at the computer and type it yourself
Go on
Good
Wait, wait, wait, you got it to put that there
You got it? No, you got it
Dude, let me move over. Okay, so you got it. You don't want to use this program, do you? And then
You gotta do this
And then
No, you you have really bad grammar. Why do you keep typing stuff wrong?
Are you like dumb or something?
I can't I thought you were smart
Oh
Yeah, just type it like that
Perfect
Now keep going
Why did you type that doesn't make any sense? No, your syntax is all wrong. Don't move over. How much?
You have to type it like this
Like that that makes more sense. Okay, does that make more sense to you?
You're trying to get a rise out of me? You're getting distracted
What's distracting me? What's the matter?
I'm close to you? What's um, I'm not that close. Is there something wrong with me being really close?
I don't mind being close to you
I think I'm getting used to how you smell
I'm sorry, I know this is stuffy, but I can't stop smelling you
So
I think um
I'm starting to like
Sorry, I didn't mean to listen to your face
I'll just wipe your face
I'm so sorry, but I've got your lips. I bet you feel so lucky. I don't have my spittle over your face from season one
Okay, I think I got most of it off
Um
You want me to say something again, I don't think I should do that
I think I hear my mom coming again. Did you decide what you wanted for a snack?
I have like goat's fish and apple juice and
and I have um
I have um
like
Doritos and
um
I don't know. What do you like to eat?
I don't know what you like
I know I don't usually
see you bring like
Food to school. Are you like poor or something?
I
Because I see you get the reduced or free lunch. Do you not have any money?
Jesus that is one of I know you have chicken tendies
A cream pie. I don't think we have that. I think I have the little mini um like Debbie rolls
Lunchables
I have some lunchables in the fridge not the ones that contain lead
And it should be made. I don't know what that is, but I can ask my mom for it. Hey mom
Mom
Yes, honey
Mom, do you have any? Do you have any chicken eggs?
Excuse me mom
I need some chicken eggs so you can't take mine
That's what my classmate wants. She wants chicken eggs. She wants chicken eggs
Whatever you need. Okay
Um
No, we don't have any
should be made uh
I'm starting to wonder if you should have done this project at his house, sweetie
Um
Can we have some goldfish?
Yeah, we can have some goldfish. Okay. Thank you
Okay, she said he's gonna get his goldfish
Um
Um, I think she'll bring us apple juice
I don't know if you heard her
I don't have any mom's strategy mom says energy drinks are bad for me. So I don't
I don't um
I don't have any
Although my brother might have some in the room
I can go sneak in but he doesn't like it when I go into the room. He gets real weird about it
I think I've actually seen one of those like dojinshi things dojinchais
um
He also likes to watch a lot of hentie. I've heard him listening to hentie. He said it's really intense fighting
cartoons
So I can't just leave him to it. Um when he's interested when he's doing that
um
Hey the goldfish mom you forgot the apple juice, sir
Give me you want apple juice, sir
Honey, I told you not to raise your voice at me like that
I'm just saying we want apple juice
Okay, okay you the apple juice, but you cannot speak to me that way
Okay, mom I'm sorry
Okay, I'll be right back
Oh
I know I shouldn't I shouldn't talk I'm just like
I just want to impress you and I don't want you to think that I'm like a pushover because of my mom or whatever
Uh
And
My mom is kind of wet. I don't know that mean
Where did you get that picture from to hold that up in front of your face? That's weird
How it's like my aunt? Huh weird. She likes to wear heels like that
I can't open this can you open this for me?
Are you to be the older one? I'm childish. What do you mean me and me and so britney are the same age we're twins
I remember others the older and then I do have more siblings, but they'll be introducing a later episode
You're a pushover regardless of your mom
I'll show you pushover get up stand it for the bed
Go on
My head's getting smaller in anger
I'll show you a pushover in a moment. Just you wait
And let's see
Pushes you on to the bed climbs on top of you
How's this for a pushover, huh?
Hmm what a pushover lick your ears. I don't think so
Oh
You know for some of them stinky you don't taste that bad
What why are you looking at me like that?
Yeah
Why are you making that face?
Why are you covering your pants with your hands?
I never get boys
Anyways, I'm gonna drink my apple juice. Oh accidentally got over me. Oh, no
I got apple juice over my head
That's not with a couple
Mm-hmm
If you want to sip yeah, I know you have your own but I'm just offering to share
Hmm
Mm
Uh
That's pretty good
Okay, so yourself
Can we hold hands I don't know my hands are sticky
It is for the apple juice
I don't think that would be a good idea
I
Aren't some wet wipes next to my bed
Sorry, I have the tendency to chew with my mouth open
No, I got off of you. I'm not on top of you anymore
I'm not on top of you
Wait, I dropped some fishies on the floor. Hold on
Um
I
Let me move my body
There you go
Oh, there's some fishies on the floor
I think I'm wearing a good floor fishies
Hmm
Ah
That was good
Why are you making that face?
I like the cheese five second rule
You get too close, what do you mean I'm too close? I'm just I'm just getting some food
You have a little something on your face
I don't know why you were eating but it's pretty tasty
Why are you looking at me like that I was just helping you wipe your face
Did I just look your face I guess you could call it that
But um, I don't know in my culture. It's normal to like
Don't worry about it, okay
Don't worry about it
Yeah, I could use a tissue, but I thought it'd just be faster
Than crossing the whole room for a tissue and coming back
Since my culture, can I do the same to me?
You
Um
I I guess
I guess you can
Um, okay, I guess I'll I guess I'll get a little closer
Um, okay
Go on
Do it
Uh feels funny
Why are you doing it like that?
Okay, stop it's not particularly me stop it
Okay
Kind of
I'm kind of sobbered on me
You're good
So you puppy
A bear a puppy
Would you be my pet?
Would you be my pet
I
Let me shrink my head
Why are you barking at me?
I it was just a joke
Do you actually want to be my pet?
It's so weird
I guess
Hmm, I guess I would have to get you a collar like mine. You can match
You
My family pets are are all over my room right now. I apologize for my my three dogs
Um millennia ronnie and
Gold mask
Where'd I get those names from um
I like video games or whatever. I don't really like talking about it though
I don't get bullied like you for being weirdo for liking video games
Your neck is what
I
Okay, gold mask you need to moon
Oh
Does that what auntie she be called the people she came over with you
You
What do you mean
She called them um slaves or something my mom says she doesn't like that word though
My mom says just just ignore them
When they come over they're so usually a different one every time she comes over they always wear a mask
My mom says she might stop inviting aunt she be over but I really like aunt she be
She has a lot of money and she has a hotel and I get to jump and sleep in the beds in order room service
As much as I want
And she has like servants take care of me whenever I need something and they will buy me stuff and get me candy
It's really nice
It's 2024 pretty close a lot of play all the video games you want
I don't know my brother says that video games are only for boys. So
Yeah
What kind of hotel it's wonderland hotel it's a nice hotel she won't let me go into the basement though
I don't know. It's in the basement, but sometimes I hear people screaming in the basement
I don't know what people do in the basement. She said it's um
Adult it's an adult playroom
Like for big kids and I'm not a big enough kid yet
So I can't do it
Hotel song from letter. Yeah, my aunt runs the hotel. You've probably heard about it. It's a very famous hotel. Mm-hmm
Mm-hmm
You play league I have
No, I don't play league
One of my friends from school does though
She's really cute. She's like a lamb and she's green
Our moms are like cool lady
I tried to play that game. I don't like it that much
Melania, what are you doing? Melania get out from under my desk
Why are your eyes so big?
Oh
Yeah, that's her mom's name. Her mom's name is Azura
She's hot. She's really big bazonga hangers. I can't help but stare every time her mom picks her up from school
What games did I play?
um
I play um like
I play like
I play like animal crossing
Well, my brother says it's a game for babies, but I don't care. I like it. I like mario pie
Yeah
They're they're pretty mesmerizing
What's the vn
A visual novel
I don't really like reading reading is for losers
And I know you're like a loser and all but like
Don't just because we're doing this project together doesn't mean they're our friends
Just because I showed you parts of my my zolehan bunny culture doesn't doesn't mean anything
So don't let it get to your head as auntie she be says don't get it twisted
Auntie she be usually gets twisted up and something because she wears ropes on her body mom won't explain to me
Not why um auntie she be does that so I stopped asking
But then your sister read all the time she does she's a loser. I don't like my sister. She's weird
She just her room is black. She always has her shades drawn
She she just like cries all the time and like she has like leaves ketchup packets everywhere
And her room just smells of ketchup. It's really weird
My mom says she's going through a phase
I don't know
No, I don't want to be friends. I don't want to be friends with you. You're just
A weirdo
Just because we hang out
One time doesn't mean
weird friends or
Boyfriend girlfriend or anything. Yeah, I said I take you to the wonderland hotel, but
Don't um, it doesn't mean anything. I'm just being nice
Hmm
I'm just being nice
Oh, you've heard of my sister she's so weird
I'm not I I still like to think about it and I thought about it. I don't want to go out with you. You're weird
But I
Like I do need to keep you around to help me with my homework. So
You'll be my pet
Got it
I'll get you
A nice leash and I'll drag you around school with it
I think that's a good compromise, isn't it?
My head bigger. Oh, and I have a really big head
Let me get a little closer
You
Will you be my pet
My my aunt taught me this trick. Do you want to see a trick?
I have a leash
I know my hand doesn't match my body
But don't worry about that. I have a leash
So I always have one on hand
I'll tighten it when necessary
Okay
And then every time you see me in the homies you have to drop to your knees and you have to kiss my shoes
Got it
While you kiss my shoes
How do I have them? I just I don't know
I have it
So will you be my puppy?
I'll take care of you
I'll call you bad name and I'll take you for walking and maybe I'll let you sleep under my bed
Okay, do you want to have a sleepover? Maybe I'll let you sleep with me by my hand
And you can call me mistress, step up in me
And
Appropriate school? Well, it's only inappropriate if the teachers find out, isn't it?
But teachers don't have to find out anything, do they?
It will be our little secret, won't it?
Looks like you're already excited to get started
Should we practice some training?
What's wrong with your pants? They look like they're getting bigger. What's up with that?
Why does that keep happening? Are you hiding something in there? I want to see
I think you should show me what's going on
And once we take care of that problem
Then maybe we can get started
Hmm
It's your phone? Your phone is very warm
Hmm, I just want to
Uh
Nah, your phone's a weird shape. Are you sure? Are you hiding something from me?
You know, bunnies have very good noses
I
Think something in there is making me sneeze. I have to check it out
It's very smells stronger than you
Hmm
There's something about it that I like
All right, are you gonna show me or what?
Go on
Oh
What's that?
Um, what is that?
Hmm
I didn't expect to see that
Um
I've never seen one of these in person before
Uh
Can I
Have a taste
Hmm
I can't believe you got the limited edition orange creamsicle from lint chocolate. It's so tasty
I know you're hiding something from me
You know, I love orange flavored stuff. I'm a bunny
Now it's a hot day too. Did you take this from my mom's fridge? I bet you did
Hmm
Whatever it can't be helped
I know my mom says she was gonna get these, you know, you really shouldn't put ice cream in your pocket. It's kind of weird
Well, it's mine now, thank you
Yum
I'm also finishing off your apple juice because you took too long to finish it
You
Thought it was gonna last longer. I don't know how popsicles work silly
You want to share him
Okay
How on make a music
All right, I'm taking it back it's mine
Don't ask why it's blue
Oh
I don't know if I can handle a little popsicle
Yeah, it's a long popsicle
Almost as big as my head
Actually, this is because of my head. Why am I supposed to fit this all in my mouth? I don't know if I can
How convenient that I can get it to change size
Look I can fit it across my teeth
Um
Wow, did you want the rest?
Oh my body oh no
Okay, I'm back
I'm sorry. I didn't mean to scream
You
The popsicle got smaller you can finish it you can have the red
There you go the leaders
Is there an earthquake what's happening?
I tend to lose my head a lot my mom says I need to control my dillahum powers better
Sorry, I got some on my fingers
I'm all clean are you all clean you need me to lick your fingers for you
Let me lick your fingers clean don't try calling for my mom she can't help you
Oh
I got it. Yeah, here I have some white
Maybe like a white beat I have wet wipes
I
Bit too good at that
Well, my brother says I'm
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding
I
Have two tips. Yeah, I've two tips, you know, I did say you could take a shower if you want
Since you said your water wasn't working at your house
Guys I was joking I was joking it was a joke. I never share my popsicles with my brothers that'd be weird
You
And in me I don't know who in me is
Oh, wait, I go to school with an in me
And an icy I always see them together. They're really best friends
They're nice
And me always usually has a weird doll with her though and she always wears um
This really old sweatshirt. It kind of creeps me out and she has this book with her all the time
I'm too scared to ask her what's in it
Let me just stop moving
I
Let's follow recipes
Timeline I don't know anything about timelines. Um, do you want to
A shower together, um, I don't think that'd be okay with my mom
Um
I see it's part of a train business. Yeah, her parents. Um her family. Um
Well, they're bears I think so I'm not really quite sure
But I think one of her relatives is in the train industry
And so she's kind of like inherited that I'm not quite sure I have heard about trains. Um on ic so I don't know
I'm not quite sure
Um, but I don't think we can do that together
So, uh
I'll just take you a towel and stuff and I'll be right back
Although the second I'm grabbing
You
Okay, um, here's your towel, uh the shower's down the hall onto the left. Um
Um
Yeah, don't don't look around
Uh
My brother's room is nearby. I don't want you to get in trouble if you go near his room or or shippin these room
so, um
Just go to the bathroom. Okay
All right later
So
Yeah
Shower noise shower noise shower noise
Alpha
I'm totally not doing anything last minute
I'm totally not pulling up a shower for you
For all the odds
So
Well, you're in the shower I'm glad you don't have a reflection. I don't know
I
Are you almost done in the shower you're taking forever
So
Hurry up I got a pee
Oh
Hmm
No
Oh, I'm so sorry. I didn't
I didn't think I heard the shower running but all the kids went in their room. So
I thought seven eight this
Left the shower running again. I am so sorry
um
Let me oh you already have a towel. I'll
Grab it change of clothes for you. Um, honey, can you go in to your brother's room?
Why are they leaving don't know about it
um
Are you having a good time?
Oh, should I you want me to leave?
Okay, I'm sorry. I'll I'll I'll bring you guys some more snacks later. How are we?
Uh
I don't know. I'm sorry. I don't know
Close the damn door
Oh
You're finally done. That's nice. How's your shower?
Um
I I thought my mom
Uh
Said she was getting some of my brother's clothes. Um, why did you come into my room with just a towel on?
If you um not
See where they were left
Um, I can um
Go grab those for you. I'll be right back
Oh
My gosh, I almost tripped over my dog gold mask. Um
Here's the clothes there you go
Uh
Um, I'll just look away when you you don't have to
I
I'm not peeking
Are you done yet
I
Need
I'm sorry
Okay, oh you look fine
I'm surprised my brother's clothes fit you
Um
You um
Your your hair is still kind of wet
Uh
You want some help um drying your hair I can
I can help move move that
Uh only only if you want I know
Uh
Let me
Let me just wipe your hair
I
Don't watch you catching a cold
What do you mean you'll catch a cold from me looking you I'm just an allergies
So
Oh
I
Wait a second you smell really good
Oh
Wait a second
Did you use my shampoo
You used my body wash and my shampoo conditioner
My stuff is expensive
Hmm
Mom gets it special for me from bun fora
And banalta
Um
I guess that suits you
Having my smell
Pain completely enveloped in my smell
I guess you're not so bad
You didn't want to use my brother's a 7-in-1. Yeah, I don't know why you bought that
I think he got off some like black market website or something. He's weird
He likes to go on this place called um
uh
Six six tune I think I don't know
He's really secretive about it. He won't let me use this computer
I don't know what kind of stuff he has on there and I'm too scared to find out
You'll pay me back. You promise
You better
I'm trying to move on my body
Um, I guess um
Are we done with our project and studying?
When are we supposed to turn this in again?
Two weeks from now
Oh
Huh
I thought it was sooner than that
I guess you'll have to come over every day so we can focus on the project, right?
We still got so much research to do
And I still have to train you
To make sure you look the most perfect little puppy
I mean
We have to
reread some passages and um
Maybe
Do some extra research with each other
Next time you should
Bring your laptop so you can study on my bed
Open my books
And then you won't have to leave my bed ever
Yeah, does that sound good?
If we get an A
I'll give you a special present
Yeah extra research
There's still a lot but I don't know and I need you to show me
Just be nice when you do, okay
You
Separation go away
Did you have a good time studying with her I think I I think I think I could tell we had a good time
You
Oh, I was muted how does the new microphone all of the new mic from the go XLR sound
Muted muted muted
Are you listening uh, I was I was hanging out with my sister in the next room
You
Oh my goodness
Bit on
My nieces are very quirky they're very interesting people
Stop corrupting my knees
The sound is tinny
My sound effects were very very loud, okay good to know
Oh, okay, so was speaking on my good to know thank you
Again, I'm still trying to figure out the settings for these things. How does this sound tinny?
Maybe it's I don't know
Hmm
I
My my niece needs to see the world. I'm gonna there's lots of different people that come into the hotel
I have to show them what they'll she's what they're like
The mic peaks when you raise your voice, okay good to know thank you. Thank you
Yes, you know she's getting it stuck or I'm gonna have to call and step she I think they do have step sibling
Because I think I think her older brother is a step brother. I can't I can't recall
I'm not super close with my sister's kids
Every once in a while, um, I'll pick up shabbani and shabbathani
She wanted to be called mistress. Oh, I don't know where she got that from
What is causing the floating head syndrome with my outfits, um
So I'll show you actually
So what I use so these are booth booth assets that you see
So let's say I'll use this one for example the one I used for shabbani
So this is literally a little asset
And
you have to
Kind of click it but the physics sometimes can be a lot
And so what I have to do
because each time
I'm going to do a zero was showing me she made a toggle where it takes her head
Her I have to go through and make a toggle where I have to literally make everything transparent besides my neck
And head and hair and ears and they're like really my lower half
And then I need to make a toggle of that so I can do it a lot easier
So it sticks a little bit better as you can see when this is the asset
It sticks a lot better when my head is the asset in vtube studio
It doesn't stick as well, but I kind of like the charm of that the little like added lower, you know
Yeah
Yeah, so like I'll show you so this is the head
I it's imported and saved as a asset
In vtube studio
I don't save it as a model
Because then I would have to change my model each time and I don't want to do that
So you can see here. Oh look
There's two of me
Um if I put this on it clips over and so but it only will stick properly
You can see the physics
Get a little wonky with it
And I've dialed down all the physics. It's just how the I think it's just how it's rigged. Um
But yeah, you can see even when it's near pinned to my model it kind of floats around
I still have to figure that out
Yeah, that's how that works. That's a little behind the scenes
It kind of looks like my hair is behind
Ha
Oh
Should be three head strikes again a different kind of boing boing
Okay
Yeah, shivers I'll be telling you
Did you pin it to a wobbly piece of hair?
Honestly, it's hard to tell because I try to pin it to
like my chest area
Or my neck and it just doesn't
Want to stick I've even minimized my model really small to see if I could place the asset over it and kind of make it
More stable. It doesn't work either
Um, I know Serenity from me knew I was gonna help me with that any other girls with that so
Um, but let's see
I will see you guys later. I am super fucking tired
She's the perfect woman remember that
Why does this have a debut under it when it should have I had some more
Actually, I'll put 3dio ASMR seems to be like get godly
Working on a project
I did more of a project than studying because I forgot my own
The thing that came up with
Okay, let's see
Hmm
Probably anybody to raid so I guess I'll just end stream
Oh, I would read to emmy, but she's not here
so, you know
Go out and do what you must in the world
And I hope you had a good time. Is there a streams later?
I believe
So have a good one. I know I still need to watch the new boys EP. I'm gonna do that right now
I'm gonna turn off my 3dio. I hope you guys have a lovely night
um
I hope uh
You didn't read your bibles too hard
Uh, I will see you around. I'll see you tomorrow. We're gonna play 80s. I'm so excited. All right. Bye everyone
kisses
Kiss
Hey, did you take a shower or something you smell pretty good? Hmm interesting
You